su corner e parmigiano senonchè
raggiungeremo dire che è molto semplice
da fare questo per fare la strada però
non devo fare
[Musica]
ma unesco piano la caffettiera lui è
pure possibile successo a me
l'acqua perché la cui voglio fare i
capelli dracma mangiare solo io
occhio e croce 1 facciamo due va bene
che avevo fame proprio la meta pasta
mamma ma che fate cenare oggi quando è
scaduto questa cosa scade domani
va bene non me la sento niente proprio
volte di fare un buon dolce sei team
uova farina 175 g ne è più nemmeno
previta mente come una spolverata di
neve a primavera ragazzi stasera sto
cucinando tanto per voi ve lo svelo
anche un voce di zucchero oggi ha
sperimentato un nuovo piatto solo per te
una deputata di torri e cardamomo e poi
so messaggi un incredibile segreto non
[Musica]
ha finora affrontato la delicata quanto
amore mio cammino nani non solo prigioni
non lo riempi in casa arrivo subito
aspetta
[Musica]
ma cosa voglio fargli pesce ma dovevo
fare vendiamo usare un filo d'olio sono
dovuto togliere dal sacchetto pochino
pedina nella vita è di ciao devo
abbinare trasporto piace perché i tuoi
due ingredienti bene 2 in casa non
potevo fare di meglio che l'aspettano ne
so che c'è allora la fumarola fresca
fresca dopo la ricetta di mia nonna
questo motore finalmente il mio
transetto degli altri o contenere tracce
di latte ha firmato la petizione se vuoi
dire no alle tracce di latte
nell'insalata non ho ancora finito
perché i soldi la rosa possa finire di
mangiata svela invece il caffè che molto
calorico e vi faccio l'orzo tra
l'origine 1530 prossimo è però poi
aggiungici l'acqua
allora il tea essere riscritte da
perfetto di una sei impazzito di
porchetta destra che di pasta fork ei
componenti smos a tucson è un magico
moto bravo banca marche faccio io vada
e tutto il giorno cucina perché lo sai
che cosa ti ha cucinato l'hai non trovò
dire una sorpresa
vabbè se proprio insisti te lo dico chi
ha funzionato il ravioli con la ragazza
è certo sono buonissimi e poi sono pure
afrodisiaci questa sera ci divertiamo
[Musica]